So if this if this part is coming out
after the event then let me tell you let
me tell you some stuff. So
$100 million as a title I thought would
be perfectly demonstrated by having a
launch of $100 million
which no one has ever done before but
you can't just do that from scratch.
It's like you have to build a lot of
things. And so then it started with okay
so I have to build this brand. I have to
put this content together. So I started
doing that and then you have to like the
like Harry Potter 7 is bigger than Harry
Potter 1 2 3 4 five I think in to six
maybe or not 1 2 3 4 5 I think in
aggregate first day sales just crazy
right and so the only way that happens
is if you continue to overd deliver on
the promises you make right and so I had
to write not one but multiple good books
to continue to give those books surface
area or rather to put those books out
there so that they would be the surface
area that people could come in contact
with my brand.
>> And so people who like line up before
the book release on Harry Potter
>> and so
the most elegant thing I could think of
is the third book in the series called
$100 million Money Models. The one
that's about making money, making the
$100 million to demonstrate that anyone
can do it if they are have the skills
and they have the patience. And so
that's what would be really elegant. I
hope I do that. We'll say, but like
that's um
>> that would be that would be super
elegant.
>> How many books would that be?
>> 100 um be like 3.3 million.
>> Okay.
>> Books,
>> which would be the third biggest book of
third or fourth biggest book of all time
of all time.
>> Below the non-fiction record.
>> Yeah. Double the nonfiction.
>> Double more than double the noniction
>> cuz cuz
>> we would we would uh we would unseat two
Harry Potter books,
>> right? Cuz what? 7 7 million is the top
>> 16 million.
>> No, top one is 14 and 12 million.
>> 142. Okay.
>> What? She's in another seven. It's the
seventh book.
>> Yeah.
>> Deathly Hallows. Yeah.
>> She's the goat.
>> She's on She's in the stratosphere.
>> Yeah.
>> World building.
>> Yeah. No, 100%. It's
>> your like business world building.
>> Oh, totally 100%.
It's the Mosiverse, you know, whatever.
Like that sounds so so sketchy. I regret
saying that. But point is
>> she's in the Mosiverse. The main
character is in the
>> I was like I don't give a about this.
She's like he wrote a book. Who cares?
Um
>> yeah,
>> you don't ask me anything.
>> Bob, what do you think about the book
launch?
>> Sorry, can I give you this?
>> Thank you.
>> Yeah, Leila's been a sport. What do you
think about the next book?
>> I think it's really good.
>> Do you think it's better than the other
other two?
I think it's
much more similar to offers but more
applicable because
>> offers is like you have to create
something out of nothing whereas this
one I think you can have something and
apply it or not have something and apply
it. So it makes it easier to apply.
>> I agree.
>> Yeah.
>> What do you think about the launch?
>> I don't know. I'm not as bold as a side.
>> You think it's a good idea? I think
what's more interesting is hearing what
it's like to prepare for a launch that
you know that many people are watching
you. I think that's more fascinating
than hearing about the book itself.
>> Should
you share some of that?
>> I don't even think people would believe
it.
>> What?
>> The amount that I've put into this
launch. I feel like we should talk about
it because I think it's not conceivable
for one and I think explaining to people
like what is it what's going what goes
inside what goes on inside your head
like what happens on a daily basis like
what are the sacrifices you have to make
does it take a toll on you does it not
take a toll on you like that's actually
what I find very interesting
>> yeah so um
fortunately unfortunately the way that
my brain works is I'm an objectivist and
so I think okay how much would I prepare
prep for a 5,000 person stage. I would
prepare like crazy, you know, for a
stage like that. And I think that we'll
probably have somewhere in the
neighborhood of 300 to 500,000 people
who are there live. And so it would be
an order of magnitude or multiple orders
of magnitude larger than that. And so it
would make sense, it would follow that I
should do 100 times the preparation. But
if I would prepare a week or more for a
5,000 person stage, then it would mean
that I would prepare a 100red weeks or
more, which is about as much as I
prepared for this event. And so a lot of
I think what people don't know is that
every single word that you have read or
consumed anywhere in relation to the
launch really in general but in relation
to this launch I wrote I wrote the money
models book I wrote the audio book that
was a gift for the affiliates who refer
10 people or more which is a whole
separate book. Uh if this is coming out
after the event I wrote the secret book
which is another book that has 24
chapters in it. Uh I have the money
models book that I wrote. Um I wrote the
12 playbooks which is like 600 pages. Uh
it's like a it's like two fantasy novels
of but business tactics. I wrote I wrote
the ACQ I rewrote the ACQ closer
handbook. I rewrote and edited made it
cleaner and better etc. The uh ads
handbook. Uh I wrote all the copy for
all the pages. I wrote all the copy for
all the emails. I wrote all the text
copy. Um I wrote every VSSL. almost
every video since there's six um in this
because we have the affiliate signin,
affiliate onboarding, we have the sales
page, we have thank you page one, thank
you page two, thank you page three, um
we have thank you page for
uh postevent one, two, three. Uh we have
onboarding. Yep. We have the other
affiliate video. So all of those scripts
I wrote the webinar
>> um which is a lot of words. Yeah, I'm
still actively writing. Well, the the
webinar is written. I have to put in the
slides now. So, I wrote the words, I put
the slides in. Um,
>> what's it like having to do that much?
>> Uh, I think it's just
I think it's looking at the mountain of
work and just being like, I will I will
make progress.
>> Do you ever get nervous?
>> Not really.
>> Concerned.
Yeah. Like if some if I'm like, "Okay,
well, if something doesn't make sense,
I'm like, this doesn't make sense. Why
would we put that there or like oh, we
can't when someone's like, I we can't do
that and it would make sense and it
doesn't make sense why we can't do
something." Trying to figure out, oh,
the tech won't do this or whatever.
That's that's that can be painful. And
sometimes that eats up like two days.
It's like boom, I have to dive deeper.
>> Like going into the warehouse and being
like, we might not have enough guys.
>> Yeah. Just stupid right?
Like we went to the warehouse for one of
the warehouses and I was like, "Hey, so
how you know, hey guys staffed up and we
they already, you know, we'd already
been given assurances that everything
was going to be fine." And then they
were like, "Yeah, we think we're going
to have 20 guys extra, you know, just
for yours." And I was like, "20?" I
like, "Well, how many books do you think
someone puts out?" And they're like,
"Well, I mean, 20 bucks an hour." And I
was like, "Can we do math here? Like 400
bucks an hour?" I was like, "How many
hours are they going to work?" Eight
straight. Okay, fine. So that's 3,200
bucks, right? Well, I did 20 guys times
times 20. So 400 an hour times 8, right?
32. Am I messing that up somehow? No, I
think that's what it's 3200. Yes. 3200.
3200 bucks. It's nothing. I was like,
okay, well, if we sell 3 million, are we
going to have a,000 days? Like what are
we what are we talking about?
>> Wait until 26 to get.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Ridiculous. So anyways, I
had to like do math with it. Just like
little things like that. Um,
>> are you sleeping much?
>> No. No. No. I can tell you actually. I
can tell you exactly how many hours I'm
sleeping. I'll tell you my last
>> put in death's door. I know saying.
>> Yeah.
>> Sean says old man mo reaper is knocking.
>> Old man mosy. Yeah. Look. Okay. So, I
got 5 hours and 45 minutes last night. 5
hours and 20 the night before. 5 hours
and 17 the night before that. 654 the
night before that.
>> You hung out with me.
>> Yeah. I got 646 before that.
>> Hung out with me that night.
>> 7:45. That was Saturday. Yeah.
>> That was on my birthday.
>> Yeah, that was your birthday. Uh 620 545
515 520
ah 8 That was a nice one 4 hours 519 618
515 so like
>> well and I love you had this tweet
that's like everyone's got battered like
no one's playing it 100%. Is it kind of
like
>> Yeah. No one's explain people like oh
like like I did dude I only slept five
hours last I said like the out of
here
like come on what are we I mean Dana has
got a baby like you mean like honestly I
think I think about you if I'm ever like
oh I'm tired I'm like I don't have a
one-year-old what am I talking about
>> you got three children you got three
most
>> yeah well yeah they don't wake me up at
night I wake up at three or four
>> never Oh yeah it's immediate yeah and so
it's never
>> Yeah it's Yeah.
>> Why you say we're all going to be
depressed after Pokémon launch?
>> You will be guaranteed. Well, it's just
it's a it's um it's a climactic event.
So, there's going to be a a down.
>> Yeah. I mean, we've been I mean, the
team isn't preparing.
>> You will be physiologically depressed.
Not like physiologically you'll be
depressed. Your cortisol, all that.
You'll get a big dump after the event's
over. But we have it. We have the nice
thing that we have that's different than
last year. Last year was one moment.
This day will be three days. So, it'll
spread it out a little bit.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Um, but then after
that it's going to be it's going to be a
little bit more little more chill. But
the thing is is fortunately or
unfortunately we're gonna have the
launch $100 million launch.
>> Yeah.
>> The event
>> and then we're going to have the first
event for the playbooks.
>> Yeah.
>> So I'm going to have to I'm going to
have to keep going.
>> So
>> we got to get some offers. Get the book.
>> We're not coming with you. So
>> all right. Are we cutting?
>> Yeah. Let's cut. Hey.